I have just chaired a meeting of the
government's Emergency Committee Cobra
where we discussed the details of and
the response to the appalling events in
Manchester last night our thoughts and
prayers are with the victims and the
families and friends of all those
affected it is now beyond doubt that the
people of Manchester and of this country
have fallen victim to a callous
terrorist attack an attack that targeted
some of the youngest people in our
society with cold calculation this was
among the worst terrorist incidents we
have ever experienced in the United
Kingdom and although it is not the first
time Manchester has suffered in this way
it is the worst attack the city has
experienced and the worst ever to hit
the north of England the police and
security services are working at speed
to establish the complete picture but I
wanted to tell you what I can at this
stage at 10:33 last night the police
were called to reports of an explosion
at Manchester Arena in Manchester City
Centre near Victoria train station we
now know that a single terrorist
detonated his improvised explosive
device near one of the exits of the
venue deliberately choosing the time and
place to cause maximum carnage and to
kill and injure indiscriminately the
explosion coincided with the conclusion
of a pop concert which was attended by
many young families and groups of
children all acts of terrorism are
cowardly attacks on innocent people but
this attack stands out for its appalling
sickening cowardice deliberately
targeting innocent defenseless children
and young people who should have been
enjoying one of the most memorable
nights of their lives
as things stand I can tell you that in
addition to the attacker 22 people have
died and 59 people have been injured
those who were injured are being treated
in 8 different hospitals across Greater
Manchester many are being treated for
life-threatening conditions and we know
that among those killed and injured were
many children and young people we
struggle to comprehend the warped and
twisted mind that sees a room packed
with young children not as a scene to
cherish but as an opportunity for
carnage but we can continue to resolve
to four such attacks in future to take
on and defeat the ideology that often
fuels this violence and if the turn out
to be others responsible for this attack
to seek them out and bring them to
justice the police and security services
believe that the attack was carried out
by one man but they now need to know
whether he was acting alone
or as part of a wider group it will take
some time to establish these facts and
the investigation will continue the
police and security services will be
given all the resources they need to
complete that task the police and
security services believe they know the
identity of the perpetrator but at this
stage of their investigations we cannot
confirm his name the police and
emergency services have as always acted
with great courage and on behalf of the
country I want to express our gratitude
to them they acted in accordance with
the plans they have in place and the
exercises they conduct to test those
plans and they performed with the utmost
professionalism four hundred police
officers were involved in the operation
through the night and many paramedics
doctors and nurses have worked valiantly
amid traumatic and terrible scenes to
save lives and care for the wounded
significant resources have been deployed
to the police investigation and there
continue to be visible patrols
around Manchester which include the
deployment of armed officers for people
who live and work in Manchester the
remains a large cordon in place around
Manchester Arena and Victoria Station
which will be in place for some time the
station is closed and will remain closed
while a detailed forensic search is
underway we know that many friends and
relatives of people caught up in the
attack are still trying to find out what
has happened to their children brothers
and sisters parents and loved ones so
please think of those people who are
experiencing unimaginable worry and if
you have any information at all relating
to the attack please contact Greater
Manchester police the threat level
remains at severe that means that a
terrorist attack remains highly likely
but the independent joint terrorism
analysis Center which sets the threat
level on the basis of the intelligence
available to them will continue to
assess this throughout today and in the
days ahead
later today I will travel to Manchester
to meet the chief constable of Greater
Manchester Police in Hopkins the mayor
of Greater Manchester Andy Burnham and
members of the emergency services who
have come to Manchester's aid in its
moment of need and as I announced last
night the general election campaign has
been suspended
I will chair another meeting of Cobra
later today at terrible moments like
these it is customary for leaders
politicians and others to condemn the
perpetrators and declare that the
terrorists will not win but the fact
that we have been here before and the
fact that we need to say this again does
not make it any less true for us so
often while we experience the worst of
humanity in Manchester last night we
also saw the best the cowardice of the
attacker met the bravery of the
emergency services and the people of
Manchester the attempt to divide us met
countless acts of kindness that brought
people closer together
and in the days ahead those must be the
things we remember the images we hold in
our minds should not be those of
senseless slaughter but of the ordinary
men and women who put concerns about
their own safety to one side and rushed
to help of the men and women of the
emergency services who worked tirelessly
to bring comfort to help and to save
lives of the messages of solidarity and
hope of all those who opened their homes
to the victims for they are the images
that embody the spirit of Manchester and
the spirit of Britain a spirit that
through years of conflict and terrorism
has never been broken and will never be
broken there will be difficult days
ahead we offer our thoughts and prayers
to the family and friends of those
affected we offer our full support the
authorities the emergency and the
security services as they go about their
work and we all every single one of us
stand with the people of Manchester at
this terrible time and today let us
remember those who died and let us
celebrate those who helped safe in the
knowledge that the terrorists will never
win and our values our country and our
way of life will always prevail